yo hey on Wednesday I got a text message
from my theater group telling me that a
package had been delivered to the
theater for me and I needed to come and
pick it up which was a little bit weird
I've been in Cornwall for the past week
so I haven't been able to pick it up
till today but I went down to the
theater and I've got it as you can see
it's addressed to Charlie is so cool
like so I'm guessing it's got something
to do with YouTube and to be probably
honest with you as soon as I got a text
message saying that a package had being
delivered for me I pretty much knew what
it was
it's a mystery package over like the
last three weeks or so like a bunch of
UK youtubers have been sent these
packages I've got a table through now
it's a pretty big package I'm quite
excited this is it yeah nobody really
knows what they are usually it says open
this on your blog like on the package
then on the back it says please open
this live on your blog please open this
live on your blog but I don't actually
have that I've already addressed but I'm
just guessing that I meant open this on
camera so I'm going to move all of like
the mystery package videos that I've
seen people have I have received a
microphone microphone or a hoodie the
body usually comes in a bag about this
size and the microphone comes in a mic a
massive box so I'm pretty sure it's not
a microphone but um this doesn't feel
like a hoodie I can feel something hard
inside so I really have no idea what
this is and it feels like a hairdryer
but I don't know why they would send me
back whatever I'm gonna open it there we
go I'm gonna send oh okay look at this
look what was happening got a little
cheese parcel rubbish on me
okay okay what have we got here I'm not
really sure this is they've given me a
load of a load of newspaper articles I'm
going to read those interfere pretty
sure there's some other stuff in the
package as well but it's gonna read read
the letter first read the letter that
came with it
hi Charlie its mystery package time oh
it doesn't say I just put that in now
before you get freaked out too we want
to tell you a little bit about why we're
doing this we're a charity and we have a
really good reason to believe in young
people quite simply they helped us save
hundreds of lives every year but this
isn't about us it's about you we want to
know what you all think for once so we
hope you're up for it young people are
getting a rough deal in the news at the
moment you all carry knives you play
video games all the time and none of you
have any respect isn't that true partly
true I mean to play video games all the
time but there's news about your
generation has to be bad news surely
you're better than that so this is your
chance to turn the tables
thousands of people log on to hear what
you've got to say you're a media Baron
yourself obviously they value your
opinions in fact your audience is
probably just as bored with all these
media opinions as you are if you spoke
up yourselves you could really make a
difference you can beat the media at
their own game
we'd really love to hear what you all
think videos comments music anything
then we're going to help you by getting
those opinions heard talkative which
that's why we've sent you these
clippings a blank pad and some pens
seriously okay what sort of headlines
would you prefer to see about your
generation what should the media really
be saying about you what should
society's image of you really be we'd
love to know it would probably be a
better use of your time than the wine
gums experiment okay now they're just
mocking me right you've sent me you sent
me paper okay I would love a microphone
this microphone might have here is
rubbish it just sucks and you've sent me
paper and pens and how about getting
your subscribers involved they're happy
to make comments about your videos or
videos about your videos why not see
what they have to say we're interested
in everything you've got to say we
promise to tell you and the rest of
YouTube exactly who we are in the next
week or so but what's important right
now is that opinions change
yeah thanks drowning horror of a boy
ambushed by predatory gang they made
lives a misery gang of four given as
bars after terrorizing residents did two
big drunk jobs flop says cancel reject
scheme hunt for girl gang who cause
trouble outside blast homes and the
Metro told
stabbed children doubles okay so give me
hens two pans black one in a blue one
you know for a bit of variety some
sellotape don't get enough of sellotape
got one of these I've got a pad which
says rewrite the headlines about your
generation okay what you want me to do
it now no no I know what to do
what do you want me to do
jeez oh god there's pennies Wow well
that stinks
how about that good headline yes how
about this am i getting closer I mean
this one looks more like a newspaper so
they've obviously put a lot of work into
this I'm just gonna go with it and I'm
going to ask you guys if you want to
make video responses to this or just
post text comments or whatever
what sort of headlines would you prefer
to see about degeneration what should
the media really be saying about you
what should society's imageable you
really be we'd love to know it'd
probably be better than your wine go
experiment what do you think what do you
think about this because I I obviously
have no clue okay bye and we say would
have preferred a microphone or a hoodie
sorry